hey guys welcome to ask ij i'm ij
justine hi nice to meet you let's shake
hands virtually of course let's start
the show
facebook question so my first question
is from annie and she wants me to draw
her a picture with my right hand because
she knows that i'm left-handed so all my
left-handers in the youtube house leave
a comment below and yes anna here's your
picture
imagine what i could do with my left
hand the one that i actually write with
how did i meet luda well i was at ces
and someone sent me an email saying hey
do you want to interview ludicrous and i
said hey yes i do what's up youtube i'm
here with ludacris now where are we at
we're at cs right ces yes las vegas
2011.
ellen wants to know what my favorite
color is and do i play any instruments
my favorite color happens to be pink and
no
i don't actually play any instruments
did i ever eat until i was sick actually
yes i did and that was at christmas let
me tell you how many christmas cookies i
ate actually i can't tell you how many
christmas cookies i ate because i can't
count that high and no it's not because
i can't count it's because there's too
many cookies to
daily booth question k money wants to
know who my youtube inspiration is
actually pretty much everyone on youtube
is my inspiration from the commenters to
the people who are actually creating
content every single person in this
community is an inspiration to me well
doesn't that sound like a bunch of crap
but actually it's true i love you guys
my favorite website well obviously
youtube is probably one of my favorite
websites but i'm also a huge twitter fan
i love facebook and i love daily booth
that wasn't my favorite website that was
more like my favorite websites but hey
they're my favorite j7b wants to know if
i like answering questions and obviously
i do like answering questions because if
i didn't like answering questions then i
surely shouldn't be doing a question and
answer show should i
what
twitter question zero 1343 wants to know
if i'm excited for little big planet 2.
now i'm actually not that big of a
little big planet fan i'm a real big fan
of fast-paced games and i feel like
little big planet just isn't fast enough
for me either vanilla or coffee
fruits or vegetables well i like both if
i had to pick a fruit i'd pick a banana
or grapes if i had to pick a vegetable
definitely carrots frost xx fire wants
to know if i could bring back any
discontinued food or drink what would it
be i don't know if any of you guys
remember that they used to have a clear
pepsi and i don't actually remember what
it tasted like but i do remember it
tasting pretty awesome youtube question
do you and jenna ever fight actually jen
and i really don't fight that often now
but when we were younger
i recall the few fights
thanks so much for watching this episode
of ask ij now i've got a question for
you guys i always do these qotv question
of the video questions where i ask you
guys something in the descriptions and i
don't ever actually say them in the
video but this time i'm going to ask you
what movie did you watch when you were
younger or did you watch recently that
totally freaked you out when i was
younger the gremlins and edward
scissorhands used to creep me out to no
end thankfully i've gotten over that
fear and i've got my cute little gizmo
gremlin
okay be sure to subscribe to this
youtube channel here that you're
watching right this second here so
you'll know when i launch new videos and
i have a bunch of other youtube channels
voila
right here got an iphone channel i've
got a vlog channel got a reviews channel
i've got a gaming channel wow i'm
getting a little out of control over the
youtube channel so
yeah okay i'm gonna go see you guys in
the next episode